it's it's mind-blowing I learnt this
when I was at uni the existence of
transcendental numbers and the name was
a selling point because I was like
transcendental you know it's a time when
you're really interested in you know
out-of-body experiences and whatnot but
the idea that mathematicians gave this
gave this name to numbers numbers you
know these are numbers that you're
familiar with like pi you can write down
as a decimal expansion you'll never get
it right but it's just a number that
you're familiar with has this property
that we just didn't know about okay
we're going to play a game and we're
going to try and we're going to try and
understand transcendental numbers with
this game the game is is reducing down
numbers to zero that's what you want to
do so the rules are you can only use
whole numbers to do it and you can add
take multiply and put the whole thing to
any power you like but it has to be a
whole number power okay so let's play
the game okay so do you have a favorite
number well I am ten ten yeah sure
that's fine
you mean 10 in base 10 turning based
yeah okay so 10 in base 10 okay here we
go let's start the game so we want to
get this down to zero so the first thing
we could do is multiply it by zero but
that you can do with any number because
any number times zero is zero that's
been bingo you can do that but that's
not very interesting but what is
interesting is that if we try and use
these rules we can go okay what happens
if I take away 10 from this we're done
so there you go so that sounds kind of
trivial but it's a really good start so
we use the whole number we use take what
about something else how about three
quarters first of all let's multiply it
by four okay so these things will cancel
you get three now we can take away three
we'll get 0s excellent but what about
something crazier what about like a
really crazy number what about like the
square root of two I think you guys know
about the square root of two yes we've
done a rationalism it's an irrational
number and irrational means it can't be
expressed as a fraction so the square
root of two is kind of a very strange
number and so this little thing here I
often say
this this little thing here is like a
little sentence it says what number
multiplied by itself gives you this
number that's the way I think of the
square root sign so I don't know what
number multiplied by itself gives me two
but that doesn't matter now what we'll
do is to try and get this one down to
zero okay first of all we'll have to
reckon I can do that well tell me I
reckon if we raise that to a power yep
what power let's raise it to the power
of two correct that's multiplying by
itself and then what are you get in the
middle are you going to get - that's
right so now you've got two in there so
what are you gonna do subtract yes some
of that so you've just you've just taken
an irrational number and with this game
you've brought it down to zero how about
the square root of negative one
we've gone from numbers that you know
and love to fractions okay to irrational
this is irrational numbers now we've
gone into what they call complex or some
some people call imaginary which is a
terrible name for it okay so what can
you do to this one here to try and get
it down to zero well I'm just going to
square it and add one there you go no
flies on you mate so there you go so
we've been able to play this game with
three or four very different types of
numbers quite quite special but what
about something else what about the
square root of two plus the square root
of three I can't do it with that so
let's see the square root of two plus
the square root of three now we're going
to square it okay so this is a little
bit of high school maths two plus two
times this by this which is two the
square root of 2 times square root of
three plus this squared so that's three
so this reduces down to five plus two by
the square root of two by the square
root of three okay so this is what we've
done we've done that they're they look
what's popped out a number that we can
use a whole number so what we'll do is
on this side we'll go five plus two by
the squared 2 by square root 3 and now
we'll take away five so we'll end up
getting two by the square root of two by
the square root of three and this is
good because like there's no plus sign
in the middle what can we do next well
we're going to square all of that so 2
squared is 4 and square root of 2
squared is 2 and the square root of
three squared is 3 ok so that dot is
another way of saying times and so that
one is two eights a two fours are 8 8 3
is 24 done so if we go 24 take 24 boom
we get down to 0 what I wanted to show
you the reason why I'm going to show you
this is because all these different
numbers look very complicated unrelated
but let me show you now let's replace
all the numbers we put in with X X take
10 is 0 for X take 3 is 0 x squared take
2 is 0 x squared plus 1 is 0 and this
one is x squared take 5 all squared take
24 equals 0 which will free expand out
so look these all look like algebra
problems so what we did was in our game
we picked numbers and we try to get them
to 0 but the opposite could have been
here let's solve for X now this is the
stuff that you get taught in school
this is algebra and it so happens that
the family that all these numbers belong
to even the square root of negative 1 is
algebraic numbers so we've actually
found a home for some of the biggest
stars of maths the numbers that have
caused huge problems and schisms what is
the square root of negative 1 square
root of 2 from the ancient times the
Pythagorean times people died because of
this number but somehow we've moved kind
of family for these numbers algebraic
numbers ok so next we're going to need
another sheet of paper we've just we've
chosen some numbers what about a special
number
what about E now this number here if
you're not familiar with it this number
is a fantastic number from maths and
what it is is that if it's a function a
function of e to the X e to any number
that you raise it to ok on the graph
when you graph it like so the Y value is
also the slope of the tangent at that
point so it's really really important to
natural growth it's like a really
fantastic number it means a lot to life
really but it's actually a super crazy
number super super crazy one of the
expressions I can show you for it is
actually in
infinite sum so I'm going to blow you
away it's one plus one on one plus one
on two plus one on six plus one on
twenty anyway it keeps going forever and
ever but can we play the game with this
number can we bring this number down to
zero using the rules of our game can we
do it without zero
can we do it with algebra that's right
oh can we well for ages and ages and
ages he's been around for about four
hundred years nobody really knew I mean
this number is really really important
and no one knew so happens you can't
can't be done it can't be done and I'll
show you why well I kind of try and show
you why because it's actually really
tricky but it was a guy called
charles hermite and he basically showed
right so I'm going to use these symbols
here because I don't know what the the
formula will be you basically show it if
you try and play the game right bringing
e to any any power that you want whole
power and timesing it by any whole
number so if you claim that there does
exist some bit of algebra that you can
bring it down to zero
he showed that you'll lead to a
contradiction basically he showed that
there was a number a whole number that
existed between zero and one obviously
there's not obviously there's not but
this is what this is what you're doing
maths is that if you want to show
something is impossible you kind of
assume that it's true and then you show
that it creates a contradiction so this
is amazing so this is what hermite
discovered and it's this is really
really a fantastic I mean this is
everyone should be excited by this
because E is not algebraic so what
number is it well it's somehow
transcends what we're capable of doing
the thing with algebra is like that's
how we build numbers like that's our
world is built with algebra like you
know any number that you kind of deal
with in your everyday life is a lot to
do with algebra just adding taking
dividing things of things to the power
but he is not so it's somehow transcends
maths so that's what they called it E is
Tran sin dental
there's actually is actually cooler
stuff I can show you other than II you
know why is because well this is an
interesting thing he wasn't the first
transcendental number they discovered a
trans Indian from Louisville I think his
name is discovered a transcendental
number a quite quite a long way before
this was about 30 years before this but
it was like through construction so he
was actually trying to find a number
based on the rules of the game that
didn't fit what's special is that E was
already it's already a superstar of math
see like people knew about it so this
was an extra piece of information but
then people asked this question what
about pi superstar the superstar this is
the superstar of maths 2,000 years old
what is pi is pi algebraic or
transcendental so you've got to imagine
as a mathematician okay
you love PI like it comes with the
territory you cannot you cannot not like
pi so this is the thing is that you
could actually add to the knowledge of
Pi you can add something new which is
incredible I mean I would die a happy
man if I could do that so this question
came up what is pi is it algebraic or
transcendental and so it was about
probably 1880s that a guy called
Linderman actually came up with the
answer he showed and again this is a
very tricky thing that he showed he
showed e raised to any algebraic number
is transcendental so for example e to
the 1 e that's a good thing because
these should be transcendental because
it's already been proven because one is
algebraic your favorite number Brady e
to the 10
that's trend in dental right e to the
square root of 2 e to the I right but
what about pi so how could you use this
fact here e to the a so a is any
algebraic number is trans initial how
can you use that fact to show that pi is
transcendental okay so this is this is
the thing again it's a proof by
contradiction so this is what he did he
said let's assume pi is algebraic
surpised algebraic that means there's a
formula for it okay what's that formula
who knows
because it doesn't exist but as an
example if you're an engineer you'd say
oh yeah PI 22 and 7 all right okay cool
so that means pi times 7 take 22 equals
0 right
as an example that's not true by the way
there's no way I'm claiming that to be
true
don't you dare cut it and say Simon
thinks that's true it's not true 2 pi 22
+ 7 a PI 22 + 7 I know I know PI 2 quite
a few decimal places so that's obviously
not true
in actual fact just just so I can tell
you another another really nice
approximation of pi is the cube root of
31 it's actually pretty close so that
could be another formula so that means
if we cube that and take away 31 that
equals 0 ok so we've got like these
phony equations this is the big kicker
this is the big kicker we're going to
use another superstar equation ok e to
the I pi equals negative 1 so this is
Euler's identity
the famous one isn't it but look with it
look what it says e raised to the I pi
is negative 1
now I pi okay if we assume pi is
algebraic that means I pi must be
algebraic so e to an algebraic number
has to be transcendental but is negative
1 transcendental it's not because we can
play the game when we can get it to zero
so by using another incredible piece of
matter in your formula I imagine like
this is like you're making a film like
you're doing a maths film and you've
just got the biggest Hollywood star in
the world to star in it right in your
proof starring in your proof so this
here e to the I PI was negative 1 if
indeed this was our break right this
would have to be transcendental so that
means I pi cannot be algebraic and
here's the culprit well it's not the
square root of negative 1 it's pi so pi
cannot be algebraic which means pi must
be transcendental
you
so there's something really tricky going
on and that's why I like it because the
tricky stuff is where all the awesome
maths is in maths perfection is
important but then anyone who uses maths
for physics or chemistry or whatever you
want to do you know then they can kind
of use approximations I'm not interested
in approximations